did you live with so you lived how long
did you live with Diana Ross oh
on and off about two years wow
wow and and is a story that I know
weren't you dating Cher before that and
did you cheat on Cher with Diana Ross of
course yes
so you're dating Cher yes did she catch
you with Diana Ross no uh what had
happened was I uh by the way both
amazing women that's not a bad thing you
can say about no I think they're both
beautiful wonderful mothers you still
talk to them sure
it was Christmas time and I what do you
get
what do you get share for Christmas you
know so I asked her I don't know what to
get you you've got everything
and I've got to go back to New York to
rehearse we're going back out on tour
and she said my best friend Diana's
there
just call her up tell her I told you and
she should take you shopping she knows
what I like
oh my God
and Diana knew that Cher loved your
penis
I beg your pardon Howie well I'm just
saying do you want it at Christmas you
said Diana knows go ahead finish well
these are semantics but I'm not
anti-semantic there you go I love what
you did he's writing these down see kids
writing entails a utensil you hold with
one of your hands and this paper made
out of trees okay so now finish it up
this is an amazing story so you are you
living with Cher at the time
well yeah but I had to go back out on
tour right but you went to New York and
she she hooked you up with your with her
friend to shop for her what happened
uh
I went up to meet Diana who was lovely
and all that and she gave me chocolate
cake
actual an actual piece of chocolate cake
oh oh everybody you're so bad no but I
was just looking at everybody's face in
the control room I'm telling Simon about
you did you break up a friendship
are were they no longer friends it's not
I think Diana and Cher stopped talking
with each other but I remained friends
because you can't have your cake and eat
it too holy crap wait they stopped
talking to each other after if you don't
swallow it doesn't count right Howie
that's very Jewish
[Laughter]
it's not Kosher go ahead
um but they stopped talking to each
other after you went to New York
I
I know you remained friends with both of
them what did you get share what did you
end up buying share
I remember going with uh by the way
Shannon love of my life we have kids
together fellow Canadian love she's very
she's a new fee yes I know stay where
you're at and I'll come where you're too
bye that's how they talk in Newfoundland
Canada no you gotta kiss the Screech she
doesn't talk like that no not like this
not like Popeye no right but those
phrases are very new why are you
bringing your wife up now I'm talking
about she's probably not thrilled with
this conversation is she listening well
tell her not to listen Oh Shannon don't
you don't listen but this is
pre-shannon that's right so we're
talking about oh but even during Shannon
I was an [ __ ] arrogant selfish
were you were you out shopping were you
shopping for Shannon with other who who
took you shopping no there's no shopping
involved I was just
shopping for [ __ ]
you're so that's not true my daughter
but if you're in a band you don't have
to go shopping okay it comes to you all
right what do you have it did you have
an open relationship with uh no no so
let's finish the one shopping spree
share what did you buy share like how
did Cher find out or you said I'm not
coming home here's your gift well
they uh
uh I wasn't privy to the conversations
but soon thereafter
I
I bought a place for Cher in New York on
Fifth Avenue and she had her designer uh
design it
it was a penthouse on top of 64th Street
it's still a lovely Place overlooking
the Children's Zoo as a matter of fact
it's an amazing Place elevator comes
right into the place you know all the
accoutrement
and by the time it was finished I had to
go back out on tour and then Cher
noticed I didn't stay there that I was
staying a few blocks away with dying at
her place right so you know she said
what's going on
[Music]